many wireless companies eliminating 3g
service this year and that means people
with older phones will have some trouble
calling 911 or other emergency services
that's right well mary jane belliesa
shares how business owners are preparing
for the transition and what you at home
can do to stay
connected as many mobile companies pull
the plug on their 3g networks to make
room for faster network services and
capabilities business owners like laurie
mann of manumark are quickly making the
switch i am on 4g but again my business
is all about connecting with other
people so it's really the customers the
individuals that i connect with making
sure that they have access michael
johnston the chief security advisor for
boss security screens says while many
carriers already notified customers it's
not that easy for others to catch on my
mother-in-law who is 86 years old
she has early dementia and she received
a notice but doesn't understand what 3g
really means phasing out 3g doesn't just
impact your phones but it also impacts
medical devices tablets home security
systems and even vehicle sos devices
make sure that you're not operating on
3g when the sunset for your carrier
comes online and then also make sure
that any of your loved ones get with
them look at their systems look at their
homes their alert devices medical alert
devices johnston also says it's best to
reach out to your internet provider to
ensure coverage i know at t is set to
shut down on february 22nd unless the
fcc
does
intervene
but
for those that still have time with say
sprint and
t-mobile and the other carriers
make sure that you are proactive
reporting from lake mead and boulder
highway mary jane balleza live local now